[public qui applaudit et qui siffle]
Oui c'est des applaudissements enregistrés.
Bonjour et bienvenue dans ce premier épisode de
Cyrusly.
Alors ce qui nous interpelle aujourd'hui
c'est une éternelle question qui refait
surface avec la une du 13 Février [2016] de The Economist
"The right way to do drugs". Ou encore Bertrand Dautzenberg, un pneumologue
qui a pris la défense de la
légalisation du cannabis, il y a quelques semaines.
Un pneumologue !?
Cyrusly?!
Alors, ça fait quelques années qu'on
le sait, le traitement de ce sujet par les
politiques français il est un peu fumeux.
Je vous rappelle les propos de Valérie
Pécresse il y a quelques mois:
"La région financera
la réalisation de tests
au cannabis
dans les lycées...".
Pff, Ok ! Faire des tests de drogues salivaires dans les
établissements scolaires ??
Je voulais même pas rentrer dans le
détail de pourquoi c'est pas possible, mais je
vais le faire quand même tellement c'est jouissif.
Déjà il faut l'accord des étudiants.
On ne peut pas obliger un test salivaire
sans motif, surtout quand c'est fait par
-SOS drogue info service-
qui n'est ni une autorité judiciaire ni
policière.
Personne va accepter !
A part peut-être Amaury qui se met
toujours au premier rang en cours de latin.
Bon courage avec ça.
Ensuite ce test n'a pas aucun effet
après un simple bain de bouche.
Et ça si c'est interdit je peux vous dire que ça causera beaucoup plus de
dégâts que la légalisation du
cannabis.
Cette déclaration elle pourrait être
anecdotique, mais elle représente aujourd'hui une
énième maladresse du gouvernement,
face à une consommation de cannabis en
France qu'il ne parvient pas à endiguer.
Petit rappel des faits: la France aujourd'hui elle pénalise la consommation,
la vente et la production de cannabis sur son
territoire
et pourtant nous faisons aujourd'hui
partie des plus gros consommateurs de
cannabis en Europe.
Selon un rapport de 2011, dans le mois on
avait 12,7 % des 15-24 ans en France
qui consommaient du cannabis,
contre 5,3% aux Pays-Bas.
Et c'est pareil pour son accès:
49.9% de la population française y a déjà goûté alors
qu'aux Pays-Bas où la consommation
est légale
la part de la population l'ayant déjà
testé n'est que de 25,7% !
Je vous rappelle qu'à Amsterdam, on a quand même dans une seule ville, 220
Coffee shop. Et si vous pensez
qu'on y vend du café,
je vous déconseille très fortement d'aller à Amsterdam.
Dites vous qu'en faite la consommation est tellement forte en France,
qu'on peut établir une carte de la
consommation des drogues.
Et pas par un sondage IPSOS, "non, non, non"
par le biais de nos égouts.
Alors je veux que la prochaine fois que
vous aurez envie de vous plaindre
vous repensez à ces personnes, dont le
travail a été de faire le tour de nos
stations d'épurations pour amasser des
échantillons d'urine et de sels.
Pensez-y la prochaine fois vous croirez
avoir un travail de merde.
Du coup, il y a un constat clair: la politique
de répression elle marche pas du tout.
On a une loi et chaque année tu as 4 millions de personnes qui s'en tapent.
Malgré 568 millions d'euros chaque
année, consacrés à la répression dont
300 millions, rien que pour les interpellations.
On reste dans le top des consommateurs
européens.
Alors plusieurs pays ont renoncé au
tout-répressif, d'autres ont même
commencé à mettre en place des
filières de cannabis comme certains
États américains,
mais en France on est très loin de tout
ça.
La France, elle fait même partie des cinq
derniers pays de l'Union Européenne qui
considère l'usage comme une
infraction pénale.
Et ça entraîne plusieurs conséquences,
déjà les coûts pour l’État, qui se
répercutent sur nos impôts.
Ensuite les filières criminelles qui se
financent par ce biais et enfin les
enjeux sanitaires, sans contrôle comment
on peut s'assurer de la qualité de ce qui est fumé ?
Le fait qu'il y ait des millions  d'infractions
là-dessus, voilà, c'est une chose. Par contre le
fait qu'il ait des gens qui prennent des
risques sanitaires, ça en est une autre...
Non, parce que si ton dealer il fait un controle qualité, moi j'ai plusieurs pote que ça peut intéresser.
C'est pas parce que c'est naturel, qu'il n'y a pas de problème de santé. Déjà,
il y a la façon qu'on a de prendre du cannabis,
généralement on le fume.
Sauf que le cannabis, il brûle moins que le tabac et il produit davantage de gaz
carbonique.
Fumer un joint équivaut à fumer entre 2,5 et 5 cigarettes de suite.
Si vous aviez encore un doute, fumer
tue et plus de 70000 français chaque
année. C'est nul !
Après y'a le cannabis en lui-même, une
étude de 2012 menée pendant 40 ans, nous
dit qu'il y a un effet irréversible sur le QI quand on en prend jeune. Et pas que !
Parce qu'une autre étude de l'Utah qui
nous parle d'une diminution du cortex
préfrontal.
C'est une zone responsable pour les
fonctions cognitives.
Donc en gros,
y'a de vrais effets sur le cerveau chez les moins de 21 ans, et je vous parle même pas
de tout ce qui est psychose,
paranoïa, augmentation du risque par
trois de devenir schizophrène... On va
pas se mentir,
c'est peut-être cool sur le coup,
mais tu peux rapidement développer une addiction, galérer avec ta mémoire, ta
concentration, bref tu peux perdre les
pleines capacités de ton cerveau :
C'est de la drogue !
Et la drogue c'est mal, m'voyez !
Mais après, faut remettre les choses dans leur contexte aussi :
c'est mal, mais est ce que c'est plus mal que ce qui n'est pas interdit.
Pour des raisons historico-culturelles, l'alcool et le tabac sont
licites en France. Alors qu'en termes
de santé publique, il s'agit des
premières causes de mortalité
dans le pays avec l'hypertension, le cannabis ça reste que très loin derrière.
Ça c'est une carte des drogues d'ailleurs.
Et on voit bien que le cannabis est sous
l'alcool et le tabac, en termes de
dégâts physiques et de dépendance.
Tiens, d'ailleurs l’ecstasy apparemment, ça a l'air pas mal.
Alors, est ce qu'il n'y a que du mauvais dans le cannabis, et bah nan,
la consommation de cannabis peut aussi apporter de
nombreux effets positifs
si elle est encadrée par un médecin,
administrée par vaporisation, par spray, par comprimé,
ou même par suppositoire, parce que
oui, un putain de projet de
suppositoire au cannabis qui est à
l'étude pour lutter contre les douleurs
des règles ! Oui !
Un suppo quoi !
Antidouleur, analgésique ou
anticonvulsif, disparition des nausées,
y'a plein d'usages,
et particulièrement auprès des
patients sous chimiothérapie
ou atteints de sclérose en plaque.
Donc c'est hyper important. Et d'ailleurs, l'apparition d'un médicament dérivé du
cannabis qui s’appelle le "Sativex" a même failli arriver en France, bon alors, il se sont pas
mis d'accord sur le prix
donc pour l'instant c'est dans les
limbes des trucs qu'on arrive pas négocier
à côté du conflit
israélo-palestinien
et de certaines série sur "Netflix" et si vous m'entendez, hein,
soyez sérieux, priorité "Netflix" !
Pour revenir sur les apports potentiels aux États-Unis, ils sont même allés plus
loin en créant des entreprises comme (Flow Ub?) et (Mass Routs?),
qui sont dans l'industrie,
encouragent la consommation pendant le brainstorming pour avoir de nouvelles idées.
Si !
Donc, on se rend compte que le cannabis, ce n'est pas forcément le démon
et qui a peut-être des choses en tirer
sans parler du fait qu'il y a un
décalage profond entre les habitudes
des français et les lois.
Du coup, sans aller à l'encouragement dans les entreprises pendant les sessions de
brainstorming,
on se rend compte, qu'il y a clairement un problème. Alors, c'est quoi les solutions qu'on a à
notre disposition?
Ben, ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'il y a
deux manières de résoudre ce problème
et de ne plus être dans une interdiction
simple: il y a la dépénalisation et la
légalisation.
D'abord la dépénalisation, spoiler: ça
n'a rien à voir avec le retrait de la
famille Le Pen.
Non, la dépénalisation de l'usage,
c'est renoncer à punir légalement
l'usage d'un produit ou du moins baisser le niveau de l'infraction
pour le consommateur. Ça ne veut pas dire que tout est autorisé
et c'est comme pour l'alcool en fait.
Ce n'est pas un délit d'être soul
mais l'ivresse publique ou l'alcool au volant, c'est interdit.
Le premier avantage, c'est l'impact
direct sur le coût de la répression
qui est réduit et sur les tribunaux qui
sont désengorgés des petits délits de
consommation.
et quand on connaît le problème de
l'engorgement des tribunaux en France,
c'est un point intéressant.
Après, forcément la question
qui se pose c'est de savoir si le fait
de dépénaliser le produit
peut entraîner une augmentation de la
consommation
parce qu'on peut imaginer qu'une
partie de la consommation adolescente
s'effectue dans une logique de
transgression de la loi et que du coup
si on autorise le cannabis, ils
s'orienteraient tous vers des drogues plus
nocives.
En gros, qu'il y ait un glissement des drogues.
Et ben on n'a qu'à regarder ce que les pays qui ont dépénalisé ont fait.
Aux Pays-Bas, la consommation du cannabis
elle est tolérée et elle n'a jamais explosée et c'est pareil pour le
Portugal qui fait aujourd'hui parti de ceux qui comptent
le moins de consommateurs d'Europe.
Et, j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête un moment
sur le Portugal.
Le nombre d'héroïnomanes a baissé de
60% en une décennie
et d'après le rapport de 2009 de
l'institut de la drogue et de la toxicomanie
le Portugal est le pays où la
consommation de cannabis des 15 à 64
ans est la plus faible d'Europe avec moins de 8% et c'est pareil avec la consommation de
cocaïne.
Et, même chez nous,
avant la loi de 1970, l'usage privé de la marijuana était autorisé et on en
consommait quatre fois moins
qu'aujourd'hui.
Donc, on ne peut pas lier si facilement la dépénalisation avec une
augmentation de la consommation.
Après, il y a une seconde alternative. C'est la légalisation.
En gros on donne un cadre légal
à un produit ou une activité.
Donc, ce n'est pas du tout une liberté totale. Ça peut être un cadre restrictif par
exemple.
Déjà, on peut limiter le type de consommateurs.
C'est ce qui se passe en Suisse en Californie. Ce n''est que pour
un usage thérapeutique. Du coup, si vous allez à Venise Beach, vous verrez des
docteurs très sérieux
qui vous ferons une évaluation médicale
pour 30$.
L’État peut aussi faire comme l'Uruguay
en 2013 en nationalisant sa production
et sa distribution. Alors, l'avantage
cette option
c'est surtout de rapporter beaucoup d'oseille à l'Etat avec des recettes
fiscales estimées à 1,8 milliards.
Et, ça peut aller hyper loin hein. Le Colorado s'est même retrouvé avec trop
de recettes sur les bras,
liées au cannabis, avec 30 millions $ de plus
que ce qui était prévu.
Et, ce n'est pas qu'une question monétaire, ni qu'une question de qualité
puisqu'en terme de sécurité, la légalisation elle permet aussi de
diminuer les traffics
via des prix bas au départ, pour casser les réseaux
puis en augmentant progressivement les prix.
Enfin bref, il y a des alternatives
sérieuses et moi quand j'entends parler Marisol
Touraine, fin novembre, qui nous dit:
"Je ne suis pas favorable à ce qu'on
mette ce débat sur la table aujourd'hui.
Maintenons le droit tel qu'il est.
Il ne semble pas judicieux, comme message envoyé, de dire qu'au fond le cannabis,
ce n'est pas si grave que ça".
Ça me rend ouf. Alors, je ne suis pas être de défendre la
dépénalisation et la légalisation du
cannabis.
Moi ce que je suis en train de vous dire c'est qu'il y a 40% des Français qui ont déjà
goûté ça.
On est l'un des premiers pays d'Europe
qui en consomme.
C'est en hausse. Ça vaut peut-être le coup d'en discuter et faire la politique de
l'autruche, ça ne va pas nous aider. Il y a beaucoup de pays qui ont pris les devants.
On a des éléments qui nous prouve
qu'il y a du bon dans ses solutions là
et quand Bertrand Dautzenberg,
pneumologue, relance le débat et ben
profitons-en pour nous poser les bonnes
questions.
Alors, non. Le cannabis ce n'est pas non plus le truc le plus sain de la Terre
et ce n'est pas trop mal que les sociétés
en contrôlent l'accès un minimum
mais sérieusement
pénalisation d'un produit consommé par autant de monde,
achetable aussi facilement,
moins nocif que beaucoup d'autres produits
légaux et qui a même des vertus
thérapeutiques
et dont la vente alimente gangs et trafics en tout genres.
Ne soyons pas stupides. J'ai l'impression d'être face à un mec
qui continue de commander de la salade au MacDo pour prendre soin de son corps.
Affrontons le problème. Il faut
commencer par renouer le dialogue avec
la jeunesse. Au lieu de ça on a quoi ? Des débats sur
la déchéance de nationalité dont on se branle complet.
Là on parle d'un problème qui fait que
12 % des français qui sont
régulièrement en infraction.
On parle de gosse qui ne savent pas ce qu'ils fument.
On parle de malades qui ne peuvent pas se soulager.
On parle de trafiquants qui font des
tunes sur tout ça.
Et ça c'est un problème concret.
La France a toujours été en avance sur
beaucoup de choses.
Maintenant, évitons d'être en retard.
J'espère ce premier épisode vous aura
plu. N'hésitez pas à le partager et à lâcher un
pouce en l'air si vous voulez en voir d'autres. Vous pouvez me suivre sur tous mes
réseaux.
Merci à tous les tippers. Vous êtes vraiment formidables.
Vous pouvez vous aussi soutenir le projet
sur Tipeee.com/CyrusNorth
et surtout abonnez-vous pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos
Love and Peace.